hey you guys welcome back to my flickers
of fear show so i decided uh because
it's now january i know i kind of went
away from the winter theme on the last
one because i wanted to do another
giallo movie because it had been such a
long time since i had done one but i
decided uh maybe not for the remainder
of january but at least for you know the
next couple reviews i decided to go back
into the winter horror movies mostly
because
this movie here uh was recommended to me
by at least two or three listeners and i
was kind of intrigued because i had
never really seen it like and then i
kind of researched it a little bit and i
kind of saw it coming up on a few
christmas horror lists it is set at
christmas time but it's not like overtly
christmas it's kind of more christmas
the way like dead end is christmas in
that you know they're on their way to
christmas but you know christmas doesn't
really have anything to do with the plot
necessarily so it was kind of like that
so this was recommended a bunch of times
so i kind of got really curious as to
why i had never seen this one or why i
had never heard of it even though it
actually has emily blunt in it in a
pretty early role for her i think i mean
obviously she's you know a big star now
but i think this might have been i don't
know if this was necessarily her first
role but i think it was a very very
early one like before her big breakout
and everything so i thought it was kind
of interesting and also
it was produced by
like george clooney and steven
soderbergh like they have a production
company and so they got the funding
through that and it's just really weird
that there's not
i don't know you don't really hear a lot
of people talking about it um you don't
there's not really a lot of information
on it like about the behind the scenes
production or anything like that on even
like on wikipedia and uh so i was kind
of intrigued so i was like okay well
i'll bite
i'll go i'll go watch this one for
another winter horror movie this is
called windchill from 2007.
i actually watched it on amazon prime i
think i paid 3.99 to rent it
i think you can watch it if you have
one of their add-ons it might be the
stars add-on i'm not real sure but i
don't have that so i just paid to rent
it and it was totally worth it this was
actually a really intriguing
little movie and that's just like i said
it's just so weird how it seemed to like
kind of fall into the cracks type of
thing
so the setup of this movie
and i'm gonna uh i guess i'll just use
the actors names on this because
weirdly i guess it's not that weird like
when you think about it but weirdly the
um
none of the characters have names uh
this is mostly two characters even
though more characters do kind of like
come into play later on uh but the two
main characters do not have names
they're just credited as guy and girl i
guess they did this i didn't really
realize it when i was watching it but
then i was like afterward when i was
reading a review of it i'm like oh yeah
they didn't really have names did they
and i think it was done
to maybe
give it more of like an urban legend
kind of feel because this does have a
little bit
of that now this was actually directed
by gregory jacobs and
kind of the only like big thing he
directed like later on was the magic
mike sequel
but i was kind of interested because
martin donovan is in this movie and i'm
actually like a big fan of martin
donovan ever since like back in his hal
hartley days so i was very intrigued to
discover when i looked at gregory jacobs
uh wikipedia page like his filmography
he had actually worked as a first
assistant director on a couple of hal
hartley movies including my favorite one
amateur and i think he also worked on
simple men so i guess that's probably
why he got martin donovan in this and
he's like playing a villain which i kind
of feel like he plays mostly villains
nowadays which is odd because he always
seemed like such a nice man
like in the hell harley movies i don't
know what it is he just came across as
it's very warm to me so it's just like
weird because the the things i've seen
him in lately because wasn't he in i
feel like he was in another one that i
saw lately maybe it was come to daddy
but i think he played kind of a kind of
a [ __ ] in that one too which it's
kind of interesting cause like i said he
just seems like a nice man so basically
this movie okay here's the setup
emily blunt plays this student at she's
like an engineering student at this
unnamed pennsylvania university
now she's going to go home for the
holidays but she doesn't have a ride
she's just she said she usually flies
but she's going to have to take a
greyhound this time around for whatever
reason
so
apparently what happens somebody like
texts her and says well why don't you
check uh you know the share the ride
share board at the university maybe you
can get a ride you don't have to take
like you know a smelly greyhound or
whatever so she actually does that
and she finds this uh what seems like
the perfect thing it's like somebody has
said hey you need a ride to delaware
that's where she's going that's where
her family is uh you know she's going
home for christmas and uh you know so
somebody's going to delaware so she
takes the phone number and she calls uh
this dude up now this dude who's played
by ashton holmes
he
he turns up with this kind of like
rickety ass car which i can't [ __ ] on
too much because my car is pretty ricky
has to not quite as rickety ass as this
one but uh it's pretty close uh so yeah
so he turns up and uh he says to her
yeah i just got kicked out of my
apartment because he's got all his [ __ ]
in the trunk and everything like that
now interestingly
this movie and it's really really hard
to talk about if i can't spoil it i kind
of feel like i don't want to but then i
kind of feel like i do want to too
because it's really hard to discuss if
you can't talk about the different
twists and turns it takes but i will
suggest if you're gonna watch this movie
i don't i don't think the uh you know
the description of it gives anything
away but don't like read anything about
it that says words and don't watch this
video before you because i think it
works better if you don't really know
what direction it's going in because you
kind of think there's a lot of
misdirection going on in this movie like
you think it's going to be one kind of
movie but then it kind of like takes
another turn and i kind of liked that
because i was like watching it the whole
time going what is this because i kind
of thought i knew where it was gonna go
and then i was like oh well this is a
new development okay let's i guess it's
going in this direction so it
it kind of like it surprises you like it
doesn't really go in a direction that
you would expect even though it is set
up
you think that it's gonna go in one way
and then it goes a completely different
way um and i actually really liked that
so like i said it's really hard to to
discuss the movie without spoiling it so
i probably will spoil it at some point
but i do recommend going into it knowing
as little about it as possible so
so she gets in the rickety ass car with
this guy
and
right from the jump
these characters it's interesting
because i mean this was kind of an
interesting choice neither of these
characters is particularly likable but i
kind of want to get into this because
this was something that i don't
i don't know if i'd say it like bothered
me about the movie but there's something
going on in there that i'm not really
sure
how i should take it okay so i'm gonna
put that that way now emily blunt's
character
from the jump she's pretty much i mean
she's kind of uh
you know an entitled [ __ ] sort of in
the sense that
apparently they kind of off-screen she
sets up that she's going to meet this
guy for the ride or whatever and she
just turns up like two hours late so
he's kind of been sitting in the car in
the parking lot like freezing his balls
off for two hours and she's just kind of
like oh yeah sorry about that but like
she doesn't really think of it as any
big deal
and then when she's going to put her
stuff like in the trunk she's like man
all your [ __ ] is in here and it's like i
can't fit my thing and she's like
shoving all his [ __ ] out of the way and
everything like that so she kind of
comes across as a little bit of like a
snotty
you know douche pretty much i mean she's
kind of like unlikable very um
you know very standoffish and stuff like
that um so she kind of comes across as
unlikable however
the guy also comes across as
kind of creepy from the start um a
little inselly a little nice guy
a little bit like that and indeed
that does turn out to be like the issue
because
you know she's just she just wants a
ride to delaware which i guess i think
it's like a five hour drive they say
uh you know in the snow and she just
basically she's like look i just wanna
like sit in the car and just get the
ride i'm not interested in making
friends with you i'm not really you know
and she pretty much says that and he
gets kind of like upset about it like
you know hey that's how this rideshare
thing works it's like if i drive you
like you have to like talk to me and
she's just kind of like oh now i'm your
in-flight entertainment sort of thing so
it's like she's very prickly but
i couldn't really blame her because this
is like a dude you don't really know
and he's kind of coming on like oh you
have to talk to me now and it's like
well you know maybe i don't want to or
maybe i'm not really talkative so he
just comes across as like really
entitled and kind of creepy and like
over
thing and so like as the ride goes on
you slowly start to discover
that because he's like oh well i'm going
home to delaware too
but then like as they're talking because
he kind of like forces her to talk to
him like or you know whines into it and
winds her into it and so
she's basically starting to think hey i
don't think this dude is from delaware
because some of the stuff that he's
saying like doesn't really make any
sense to her
and so she kind of like trips him up
with this trick question and then she's
like [ __ ] you are not from delaware
it's like what the [ __ ] is happening
um you know you basically he got her
into this situation under false
pretenses which like i said creepy
so uh so yeah he's basically comes out
with it later
that
um he knew that she needed a ride to
delaware because he totally like he sat
behind her in class she never noticed
him before because it's like a big huge
college class it was like a philosophy
course
and i guess he was sitting behind her
and noticed that she was texting her
friend about oh she was going to take
the bus home blah blah blah
and so he real quick
ran out there and put something on the
board like saying hey i'm driving to
delaware with the number like in the
hopes that she would see it
and so he engineered this whole entire
thing and it turned out that he had
bought a bunch of groceries like her
favorite foods which what the [ __ ] how
did he even find out about that like i'm
not even i don't even think tom does
what my favorite foods are
we've been together for like 10 years so
it's like how would this like [ __ ]
stranger find this out and he even says
something like to her like because she
says i'm gonna get they were talking
about like laser eye surgery yeah i'm
gonna get that like over the break and
he's like but you look so good in
glasses and she's like how would you
know that like i don't wear them outside
of my dorm so obviously this dude is
like [ __ ] stalking her right so at
this point she's like really mad and
like i said as unlikable as she comes
across as the at the beginning like she
does come across as kind of like this
kind of a douche you know what i mean
because she's like oh yeah i'm two hours
late yeah sorry about that what's what
is this piece of [ __ ] car what is this
what she's always like complaining but
the far the further it goes on and you
find out really like [ __ ] dastardly
[ __ ] that this kid did that this guy did
to
get her alone in the car because he has
a crush on her even though she never
noticed him because like i said they
were in the same class
um is really
i mean [ __ ] i would have been like i'd
have been like you let me out of this
[ __ ] car right now there's some
serial killer [ __ ] and i'm not having it
and so she's like really mad about that
but understandably but she's kind of
like well i still need to get home and
you know she's
kind of gonna leave and then kind of not
it's like you know it just doesn't work
out that way
so what ends up happening they stop at a
gas station and then there's like a
little bit of foreshadowing where
i don't know like everybody in this like
rest there's like a gas station with
like a little restaurant or diner behind
it and they're all kind of like looking
at her weird and then like she goes in
the bathroom and like she gets locked in
there and then she's like banging on the
door to get out but like no one opens
the door so there's this kind of this
weird thing where you know obviously you
guys heard me banging on the door why
didn't you let me out so that was kind
of like a weird situation too now
shortly after that
uh the guy
decides he's gonna get off the highway
and go on this other uh obviously not
that used highway like i think it's
called highway 606 and it hasn't been
plowed like the main highway has
and so he goes down that way and she's
like what the [ __ ] are you doing like
get up you know get back on the highway
you dumbass
and he's like oh no this is a shortcut
it's a more scenic route and like i said
at this point you're pretty sure you
know where this [ __ ] [ __ ] is going
and i'm sitting there like
like yelling at the screen sitting there
going stab him stab him right now it's
like this is not gonna end well because
it's like obviously he's been stalking
her he's like really creepy it's just
like the [ __ ] that he's saying he's just
like oh this is how it always goes with
with women blah blah and i'm just like
you are so [ __ ] creepy and she even
calls him like a stalker at some point
and i'm like yeah exactly you need to
jump the [ __ ] right out of the car right
now and like go get a greyhound
somewhere else because this is not cool
and probably she should have i mean even
though this doesn't go the way that you
think it does that's kind of where you
think this is going so they set it up
like she's in a car with essentially a
crazy stalker who's maybe gonna like
murder her
so but that's not how it goes though not
exactly
so they go and like they're on this
[ __ ] road in the middle of nowhere
and she's just like what the [ __ ] go
back to the [ __ ] highway like there's
a you know snowstorm coming like the
weather's kind of shitty or whatever
and then it so happens that they're
driving along this stretch of road and
this other car like comes at them and
like runs them off the road and then
they can't really find like where that
car went to
so they kind of crash into a snowdrift
like the car is not that [ __ ] up but
it's too [ __ ] up to move and it's kind
of like stuck and i think like the gas
tank cracks so like all the gas drains
out and [ __ ] like that uh but they're
both ostensibly okay
so now not only is she stuck with like
this [ __ ] creepy ass stalker
um who's masquerading as a nice guy
but now the [ __ ] car is stuck in the
middle of nowhere and the cell phone
doesn't work and all this other kind of
stuff so they're kind of like stuck out
there now as i said at this point
you know you have
uh two people who don't know each other
this girl she's trapped with a stranger
she doesn't really know exactly where
she's at the weather is closing in
they're stuck there they can't get any
help and so you think that it's going to
go in that sort of direction where it's
like a thriller kind of direction but
then spoiler alert
this goes in
a weird
supernatural direction
which maybe you're not expecting now
this is kind of going back to
some [ __ ] that the guy said before about
the philosophy class and he's talking
about uh nietzsche and he's talking
about eternal recurrence and she admits
to him i guess he thought in his mind
that she's like oh this is my
philosophy chick because he's a
philosophy major but she's like look i'm
an engineering major you know i just
took philosophy because i needed an easy
like humanities course to take uh you
know and i heard this teacher was an
easy a so so that's the only reason why
she's in there so she thinks that
eternal recurrence means like
reincarnation and he's like no that's
not exactly what it is it's
reincarnation you know you die and then
you come back as somebody else or in
another body or whatever whereas eternal
occurrence is just the same [ __ ]
happening of like living the same life
over and over again so they're
kind of hinting that
this movie is going to go in that
direction but like i said it's that
really doesn't happen until maybe the
third act the first thing that happens
after the car gets stuck and obviously
you know at some point they can still
run the heat and the radio and
everything like that but then like the
you know the gas tank is cracked and all
the gas runs out so they can't really
run the heat anymore so now they kind of
have to like rely on each other for
survival because it's like [ __ ]
freezing right and so there's that whole
uh issue coming up as well
and then they start seeing
people in the woods like the first thing
is she's in the car by herself like
where he's he says oh i'm gonna go back
to that gas station we stopped at and
like get some help and he goes but then
he comes back like way more quickly than
he should and he's like oh it was closed
and she's like [ __ ] it's closed
she's like they're supposed to be open
24 7. uh you weren't even gone long
enough to have gotten there so what the
[ __ ] is your deal so like i said you're
not really sure like what his agenda is
like you know it's something bad uh
because of all the [ __ ] that he's
admitted so far but you don't know
exactly like what he's up to
so she like arms herself with a pair of
scissors uh and you know it's just kind
of like you stay the [ __ ] away from me
even though we both have to get in the
car because otherwise we're gonna freeze
to death but then they start seeing like
he goes back to while he's gone she sees
this guy like walking down this the
bridge and she keeps calling to him and
says like hey we need help and all this
other stuff but he doesn't like turn
around and she's like what the [ __ ] and
it's like it's really really weird and
then she goes into the woods like to pee
or something like that and then she sees
like all these other people like these
dudes that look like
priests or something there's like a
whole bunch of them out there and she's
like what the [ __ ] like who are all
these people and then like she's
talented like yelling at them and [ __ ]
and they're not like answering they're
just like staring at her all creepy and
it's just like it's really really weird
so they're just kind of like i don't
even know what the [ __ ] is going on but
i keep seeing all these people and it's
like really scary
so now they're like stuff get stuck
inside the car for a while it's getting
really cold
they start to kind of like befriend each
other a little bit which like i said i
guess in the situation maybe that would
happen
but
i kind of feel like if it was me like i
said if this dude had basically straight
up admitted that he had been stalking me
got me into this situation under false
pretenses he's not even [ __ ] from
delaware he lives like 10 minutes away
from the campus but is willing to drive
like five hours just to get her alone in
the car with him i'm like that is some
scary [ __ ] i think what while i still
had the scissors and like they're like
wow it's cold in here i'd have been like
yeah i'd have been like i'm gonna stab
you and holly you out and for warmth
like a taunt on it's like i think that's
what i'd be doing and i think [ __ ] would
have worked out way better i'm just
saying she probably should have done
that before the car crash but you know
but i didn't so i didn't really love
the way they kind of she kind of like
softened toward him a little bit i mean
like i said they did have to help
themselves to help each other out
because of the situation they were in
but
i don't know if i'd be willing to go
that far me i don't know maybe it's like
a survival situation
and i also didn't like that
even though he turned out to be spoiler
alert kind of like an okay guy like he
doesn't do anything bad to her and
actually like helps her a couple of
times
but they kind of give her a little bit
of a of some dialogue where she's
talking about oh you know i'm so
difficult
and
i don't know i kind of felt like the
movie and like i said maybe this was
just me maybe this is just the way i
took it but i kind of felt like the
movie was
trying to make him sympathetic and
trying to make her unsympathetic and
almost trying to like make it seem like
you know oh i'm such an [ __ ] and i
should have been nicer to you and i'm
like [ __ ] that i'm like no way
it's like i did not like i said she was
kind of a douche at the beginning like
before she knew anything about him so
it's like i'm not
forgiving that i'm just saying once she
found out what his agenda was it's like
i would not
there's just no way i would not have
like softened towards somebody like that
because that's like not forgivable
behavior but yeah so i didn't really
like that they kind of made a thing it's
like yeah i'm so difficult and i should
have she doesn't say i should have been
nicer to you but that's kind of like the
implication like where the story goes so
i that's a little bit of a complaint i
had maybe other people didn't read it
that way but it did kind of come across
that way to me um so you know take of
that which you will
but yeah so they start seeing all these
people in the woods and essentially
uh what ends up happening like they're
stuck in the car and then
martin donovan shows up as a cop
and they're like oh thank god you know
we needed help and blah blah blah but
then it turns out this cop is like a
villain now the cop and all of the
people that they've been seeing in the
woods again spoiler alert are all ghosts
they're all dead people essentially this
stretch of road and like i said this is
kind of like this urban legend aspect
coming into play again this stretch of
road highway 606 is kind of like as
urban legends say like a haunted stretch
of road where all of these terrible
things have happened um you know all
these people have gotten killed and
indeed the cop played by martin donovan
was a cop back in i think the 50s and he
was essentially a serial killer and what
he would do his shtick was he would run
people off the road on this particular
stretch of highway and then kill them
and so
he's come back like for more people like
his victims are there there are other
people there that you know just died
around this area so it's kind of like
all these ghosts and then it kind of
goes into the whole eternal recurrence
thing where
sometimes things happen
and then like [ __ ] goes and then like it
goes back again like to some other point
almost like it was a dream but not
because they
because the both of the characters like
remember it so it wasn't a dream uh so
there's that kind of whole situation too
so i kind of like
um i kind of like the way that you think
you know how this shit's gonna go you
think it's gonna be oh my god i'm stuck
with my [ __ ] stalker like out in the
middle of the [ __ ] snow
choked wilderness and i'm [ __ ]
and it does kind of go that way for
about the first act but then when you
see the other people walking around the
woods i'm like wait what the [ __ ] is
happening now like with the ghosts and
then because at first you didn't know
there goes because they just look like
regular ass people but as it goes on it
becomes clearer to you that these are
all like you know people that have died
on this stretch of road that are still
haunting it and it's like an urban
legend type thing i really like that it
went in that direction like i said it's
not not the most original movie ever
it's not you know it's it's a pretty
small uh film
uh but honestly it was pretty effective
i thought and it really even though the
characters both the characters are kind
of unlikable at the beginning
i think the setup of it was intriguing
enough to like keep me
into it
until like [ __ ] started going crazy and
like [ __ ] started going into
supernatural direction which like i said
i totally did not expect i thought this
was just gonna be like a thriller like
an isolation
trapped with a creep kind of thing and
it's not
really like that they set it up to be
like that but then it's like a
misdirection and it goes like in a bunch
of crazy like ghosty directions and i
kind of like that you don't really see a
lot of movies that
kind of take a hard right turn like that
and i kind of like that it did that i
didn't see it coming and i thought it
was like actually pretty well done now
this is from 2007 some of the cgi is a
little
me but you know what are you gonna do
it's like it's a low budget dude it's
not that bad but there were a couple
shots where i was just kind of like all
right but um you know what i mean but
i'm not gonna like [ __ ] on it too hard
because like i said
very low budget honestly i don't even
think that this got a theatrical release
in the u.s if it did it was very very
limited i think it did get a release in
maybe britain
but i don't really know how well it did
over there it's just it's very strange
that
this movie which like i said now that
emily blunt is like a kind of a big star
you would think that people would kind
of go back and revisit this as this
being like one of her very early roles
and she's actually really good in it but
yeah it just seems like
i hadn't even heard of it until and i
wouldn't even have watched it uh if a
couple people hadn't recommended i had
like two or three people because when i
was talking about doing winter horror
movies they're like oh you got to see
wind chill because you know nobody talks
about it really so i was like okay well
i got to see that if if that many people
have like recommended it it's just
strange that you don't hear more people
talking about it like i said it's not
like it's some big like genius movie
that nobody forgot about it's but it's a
pretty solid
winter horror movie and you could
totally watch it as a christmas horror
movie too like i said it's not a
christmas christmas horror movie as in
you know santa is coming like strangling
people with like [ __ ] christmas
lights or like
you know braining them with candy canes
or anything like that it's not like that
it's basically just the setup is we're
going home for christmas break and it's
a very very snowy you know wintry kind
of atmosphere so i mean if you're
looking for something like that and
there's you know some christmas or
winter horror movies you haven't seen
definitely give this one a watch and let
me know what you think about it uh let
me know if kind of the thing about
her kind of warming toward the creep was
bothersome too it kind of bothered me a
little bit it didn't ruin the movie or
anything like that but as it went on i
was just like don't be nice to him stop
it you shouldn't have been nice to him
he's a [ __ ] creeper it's like he's
[ __ ] stalking you he knew exactly
like what her favorite meal was
which like how the [ __ ] did he even know
that like what is he doing like is he
going through her phone it's just like
it kind of creeped me out and i was just
kind of like so i don't think that i
don't know i i don't think she should
have been nice to him and [ __ ] like that
and like having her feel bad at the end
like whenev when what happens to him
happens to him it's just kind of like i
don't know it just it just kind of
bothered me but let me know if it
bothered you as well because i know some
of you have seen it because i know a
couple of you recommended it to me uh
but yeah this is a pretty solid uh you
know holiday
horror movie kind of a thriller but with
a supernatural twist to it so uh let me
know what you think about it in the
comments and i will see you guys on the
next flickers of fear bye